here on our show we want to turn the
spotlight on some women
and young ladies who have paved their
own way to success
they are fearless they are resilient
they are wild flowers and we are
so happy to introduce you to our very
first of many wild flowers to come
skateboarding sensation sky
brown has set her goals high literally
and is said to become one of the world's
youngest olympians
at just 12 years old
a few months ago a devastating fall
actually almost ended that dream but
skye refused to slow down and she got
right back up this video um may be
difficult for some people to watch
uh because it shows skye's actual
accident so
be prepared and take a look
[Music]
i don't usually post my falls or talk
about them
because i want people to see the fun in
what i do
and i just want everyone to know that
it's okay don't worry
i'm okay it's okay to fool sometimes
and i'm just gonna get back up and push
even harder
[Applause]
skye you're so amazing
oh my gosh thank you so much oh my gosh
how are you feeling now of course i have
to ask
i'm feeling awesome back on my
skateboard
i'm surfing now too which is awesome
because i missed it
i had my castle and i couldn't do
anything i
hold you in the highest regard i really
do you are amazing
oh thank you i was watching your like
some of your movies this morning and
you're amazing
oh thank you this guy and i've always
thought that girls should do what boys
do while getting to be
girls and i mean you are the living
example of that and you have so
much to teach young girls another life
lesson
that you teach people through what
you're doing and how you're behaving
and surging forward is when you fall
you get back up yeah you know on
instagram everything looks perfect
i mean like no one shows them falling so
i thought
you know we've awful sometimes
and i also wanted to show that even when
you fall i'm gonna push back harder
actually we have an incredible video can
we show that you have some footage of
you getting
right back up and on it i've got a
visual for this
i mean oh my gosh if that isn't the
perfect visual metaphor
for how it's done skye i mean you just
show such strength and resilience now
you
are supposed to have been in the 2020
olympics what is it like
when you have a goal line and it gets
moved
how are you handling that and what's
your prep for going to the 2021 olympics
i mean i was definitely bummed i
thought that my dreams were done like
i was like fading away but it just gives
me a longer journey to get better
and just push even harder and i'm
excited to see all the girls next year
and
see what they got it's gonna be cool
once again skye you have blown my mind
you're like you know what i just have
now
more time to work on my craft and get
better
who are you how do you know so much
there are monks on mountaintops that
have like
worked for years to get where you are no
thank you oh my god and i just have to
say that you're just
so beautiful and so cute and
pretty on the inside and pretty on the
outside and
smart in here and brave in here and we
just love you here
and you know what we have a little gift
for you if that's okay
daniel do you mind rolling her in thank
you so much
so um i wrote a book called wildflower
and i too love uh
watching girls do what boys can do but
be
girls while they're doing it and
supporting each other and having each
other's back
so we got you a wildflower helmet and a
wildflower skateboard
and i am sure that you have very
particular gear that you need to do
so if anything consider this wall art
and a reminder
that we truly celebrate your journey
because sky i am forever changed having
met you and learned about your ability
to be this wise and this strong
at 12. so yeah that's what i want to do
my dream is to inspire girls and
you can tell them you can do whatever
boys can do and i'm actually coming out
with a song
that explains that you can be pretty you
can get your nails done you can get your
hair done
you can do whatever you want and still
be tough
and do sports well skye
keep writing music your next song should
be
i am limitless i can be everything
so thank you and we'll be checking in if
that's okay
yes thank you so much we love you skye
thank you so
[Music]
much
you